POLICE RADIO:
78.5, code six.
(GAVEL BANGING)
File number 26449,
Oscar Fernandez.
Answer the question
with yes or no, please.
(COURT INTERPRETER TRANSLATES)
-Was it true that you
were born in Honduras?
-(COURT INTERPRETER TRANSLATES)
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-Si.
-JUDGE: Why did you choose
to enter the United States
illegally?
-(GLASS SHATTERS)
-(SCREAMS)
(CRYING)
-(OSCAR IN SPANISH)
-COURT INTERPRETER:
or they would kill me.
JUDGE:
And did you join the gang?
(MAN SPEAKING IN SPANISH)
(MOTHER CRYING)
MAN 2: (IN SPANISH) Let's go.
(POLICE SIREN BLIPS)
-(SPEAKING IN SPANISH)
-Si.
BOY: (SPEAKING IN SPANISH)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
OFFICER:
MAN 3: (IN SPANISH)
Take your shirt off.
MOTHER: (SPEAKING IN SPANISH)
OSCAR FERNANDEZ:
(SPEAKING IN SPANISH)
(MALE PRISONER
YELLING IN SPANISH)
Did you take part
in criminal activity?
MALE TEEN: (ANGRILY IN SPANISH)
You're a first-rate killer!
JUDGE:
Please answer the question.
(OFFICER 2 SPEAKING IN SPANISH)
JUDGE:
I will ask you one more time.
Answer the question!
Put your headphones
-back on now.
-(COURT INTERPRETER TRANSLATES)
(SPEAKING IN SPANISH)